Republicans are hoping president Trump
will reconsider after threatening to
impose steep tariffs on steel and
aluminum imports perhaps as soon as next
week some in Congress have tended to
roll with the president's policy
statements knowing that mr. Trump's
ideas can change but lawmakers are
acting with urgency on fears that the
tariffs would spark a global trade war
and stall recent gains in the US economy
some US trade partners are warning of
retaliation if the u.s. hits them with
tariffs the continuing threat of a trade
war send stocks lower on Friday the Dow
rallied from a triple digit deficit to
close about 70 points lower Friday's
loss came after a 420 point drop on
Thursday here to discuss the impact of a
possible trade war is CBS news business
analyst Jill Schlesinger Jill good
morning good morning so is this in line
with the president's America first trade
policy is that what this is I think so
and you know coming on the heels of just
about a month ago when we had those
tariffs on the solar panels and other
appliances I think it is somewhat
consistent but look the critics are
really worried about this one because
this seems to be taking it to another
level and the fear is that this could be
the beginning of something much bigger
and retaliation from some of our trading
partners like Canada and Mexico we're
already negotiating NAFTA with them this
could really hurt much of our
negotiating stance with these countries
Jill the EU has already sort of
announced some very pointed retribution
if you will they seem to be not
necessarily surprised but they have
their ducks in a row oh yes this was
from the European Commission we have
tariffs will be on Harley Davidsons
bourbon and blue jeans so that's quite
pointed I don't know if that's gonna do
anything but look this just shows you
these are our allies right so Europe and
not only that but we have a lot of the
people who in the Canadian countries
that are sayings like this is a big
problem South Korea we're starting to
negotiate with them over issues around
North Korea so again this these are our
friends who are saying why are you doing
this this has broader implication
president jill has tweeted that trade
wars
good our trade wars ever good well I
don't like the word war in anything so
my mind when it's war it's bad trade
words are not good they can lead to
really big problems when it comes to the
global economy so again will these
tariffs undo our glue our economic
progress right this second probably not
but if we see retribution from these
other countries that could start to get
into some very thorny territory the
concern among economists that I speak to
is no it's not this but it's something
the next thing and if all the sudden
we're all fighting this could really
slow down world economic progress and
some of them said that this could
actually lead to a global recession
well Jill it's also beyond overseas
there's a domestic audience that could
be hurt here right the agricultural
sector which is a large part of the
president's base could be very injured
by these yes there's this very
interesting because although China does
not actually export a lot of steel and
aluminum anymore to the US because
that's changed over the last decade some
of these measures will hit China and we
export quite a bit of soybeans to China
and so the agricultural sector is very
fearful that the retribution from China
could really hurt their industry so on
one hand you've got a winner you say
anyone in the domestic steel and
aluminium business feels great about
this but there are losers and it's the
agricultural business it's the car
business its beer companies that have
aluminum cans or aluminum products used
in any food product packaged food
product these are the losers and they're
worried that they're gonna lose not just
business but they could be forced to
actually cut jobs and so that would
obviously be the opposite of what the
president some people in the in his own
party are calling this a potentially a
job-killing tax hike I mean is that at
risk here um I don't know if this
particular issue will be I think that
what we have to see is if there's
fallout in the other industries it could
be again we don't have a lot of details
what we know from the president is
twenty five and ten percent tariffs will
be coming next week we should get more
details there could be carve outs for
certain countries as well and certain
industries so until we get the details
we don't really
know what we'll come back the legal
review is not even completed and it
remains to be seen whether there could
be a World Trade Organisation rebuff of
the legal precedent for this yeah
although that left two BC yeah and the
president has not had kind words for the
WTO so maybe he doesn't care about that
well we shall see Jill sessions are
always good to see you okay